fonte is a special guy uh it's crazy how
historically slept on he is how talented
he is he's amazing singer too you got a
singer singing or rapping singing yeah
because he could sing he's what was the
uh projects He was putting out foreign
exchange foreign exchange this is very
much the producer's name uh Nicolette
yeah yeah Nicola was very talented um
yeah other side on my album is
definitely fonte and shout out to be my
Fiasco who's um signifan's extremely
talented singer from North Carolina it's
very much in the early foreign exchange
house bag
which was some of my favorite stuff like
you know I was a rap nerd fan but little
brother as far as like even the samples
ninth would pick or fonte getting into
the foreign exchange bag kind of
not of course introduce me to r b but as
a young kid that was such a hip-hop nerd
it made me
pay attention to it and start to do the
Deep Dives I had done with the hip-hop
[__]
yeah so fonte being on this r b project
is like such a full circle moment
because so much of what he was putting
out when I was 12 years old was
on this album like what I started to
appreciate within r b came from that
type of stuff do you like Minstrel show
or the listening more
um this will show I don't know if I'm
allowed I don't know if either of us are
allowed to say that I like oh I think
yeah that's the name of the album but I
[__] love mystery
um listening of course is incredible and
a classic but
as much as I am their underground rap
nerd fan I am very much
just equally as big a fan of
hip-hop that people would say isn't real
hip-hop like popular hip-hop right I'm
really into that type of stuff and the
minstrel show to me was the perfect
balance for little brother where they
had to try some [__] where their their
core fan base may not like but someone
like me loves that [__] like go go to
Atlantic go try to get a hit record
because I like hit records I'm not that
nerdy fans like don't sell out like not
sell out a little bit it could work a
hit a hits a hit for a reason it's you
know and I mean of course they they did
but they ran into politics um with
loving it but yeah to me musically like
menstrual show is is perfect the
listening is very much
in that college dorm which and you kind
of look like Joe Scott a little so you
probably were like yo Joe's gotta yes
well I can make it too
he does yeah shout out to Joe Scott and
every time I go to his restaurant in
Atlanta the staff always asks me if I'm
related to him every single time
Joe's cousin no
just just a fan
that's big to have fonte on the project
uh you got drums on there yes uh Ari
Lennox who else is on this James Foster
boy is on the project at least I mean
can I brag of course
maybe I'm the only one that finds that
[__] insane I don't even know who
that is you don't know who James
Foxworth is uh he's probably one of the
greatest writers of all time are you
familiar with cocaine 80s yeah of course
yeah he's the singer of cocaine oh [__]
see yeah uh do you like the 2020
experience by Justin Timberlake and 80s
was the [__] that um no idea no ID
produced I just was with no ID last
night that's crazy let him know we want
another cocaine 80s project
um
but uh yeah he's also wrote All of 2020
experience for Justin Timberlake he's
working for my favorite Justin
Timberlake album yeah he's he's a legend
to me and cocaine 80s
is by far one of my favorite groups even
though there is only four mixtapes I
remember yeah those tapes were crazy and
I was even looking up old tweets when we
put that record out and it was kind of
like a really cool full circle moment
and made me like feel a little Standish
about the amount of times like I was
tweeting James Foxborough in 2010 but yo
it's crazy how long ago that is bro if
you think about like
I was just talking to my boy because I
was every time my high school and I was
like bro high school was 20 years ago
20. like
that shit's crazy that [__] feels like
it was like six years ago like
it's just terrifying to look at what I
thought
for sure you know I've had to delete so
much [__] on my Twitter and not even on
like the cancellation that's not what
I'm talking about pauses and no homos I
had to take off my Twitter timeline
that's one thing yeah
that's just a whole separate issue just
looking at like just dumb [__] like you
really like you really thought you were
smart at that age for sure even I was
really talking very confidently on
Twitter at 21 years old like I really
had the world figured out for sure and I
was like judging other people and the
fashion [__] was great even like when
you guys did that blogger thing in the
old boy dressed uh he had the Good Wood
[__] yeah and I was like damn that
was that was a wave The Good Wood and
the [__]
loud ass ten deep and I had a 10 deeper
long sleeve shirt on that man all that
[__] was a diamond supply this they had
a snapback [__] it was [__] crazy
Karma Loop era Karma loop I remember you
go on that Karma Loop but you just see
what I would just get whatever's on sale
yeah they have like all the little
independent Brands and [__] I got so
many random just hip-hop teas like
Rocksmith and all that [__] like